okay try g6 hmm let's go for this
straightaway I'm welcome to a queen
exchange I one of the one of the things
I said to myself just before playing
this was if the Queen's are off one
thing I like is that the night won't be
able to bother me so quickly pivoting on
f3
something I can force right now is a
dark square Bishop exchange so this is
looking quite long-term but I think it's
okay to do this maybe maybe I could
sneak in some other moves first this I'm
guaranteed
square bishop exchange if i want it take
take clean side castles this move with
then bishop here kind of bothers me some
I'm going to hold off I'm going to get
these two moves in and then maybe if I
still have this option I'll do it
okay let's get my knight here so
oftentimes if you're gonna have a bishop
on this square you wanna well I don't
know what what I'm saying there I just
sometimes see this kind of organization
of a dark square bishop here or knight
here sometimes a light square Bishop
Knight here so you'd have to go with the
bishops before Knights anyhow so my
option is still there and I think I'll
take it under a better scenario now that
this bishop has already taken a step so
some
I'm benefiting a little bit more by
waiting to play h6 and I do not want to
I'm just gonna say I don't want to
castle guess what it's illegal so let's
play here this is where I really want to
be with my king
stop the knight from doing anything
exciting
controlled position maintain this point
if ever challenged similar to the last
game I have a square to work with once
more looking to play against that guy
one way or the other
good Bishop versus bad bishop or a good
night versus bad bishop and I think
they're trying to do similar and it may
be successful
actually well King needs to go here I
don't have this as a reply because of
this okay they're not going for that
move after all let's go here stop this
and prepare to get my knight back in the
ball game I like my position
and let's go here straight away I'm
gonna say yeah they still have this
option oh and maybe because of that
option I should have defended my knight
first so that this isn't to move because
I could take the pawn so this was maybe
an error yeah I'm giving this
opportunity for this yeah I shouldn't
allow that okay I guess we're just going
to play a night game
seems that way now you take me night
just a hair my best piece right now the
downside is that white can maybe sneak
in h5 okay let's maybe prevent that
altogether so a quark grip battle on the
Kings side what's happening on the Kings
side so there's some pot with the pawns
their symmetry on the Kings side I'm
looking elsewhere now where are things
different I think I would like to have
just one rakov I'm going with this one
because I want to expand on the Queen
side see what we could get here this is
desirable to preserve my knight on c5
how might things shape up over here
forever this there's a new square for
this guy if ever this well again if they
were capturing to have the bat this guy
needs some work let's just go here to be
mindful of the clock especially in this
position type where I think it will
always require some calculation with
both Knights on one night there's enough
calculation to that you know that much
more so what's the plan
okay to go here and then try and
activate my rook here takes takes this
night will be quick to jump in here can
I try to go somewhere else like on the
kingside look for a break here oh I
should maybe try to break down this
point I can put both my Knights here um
maybe I should start with the
non-committal let's put peace pressure
here and then I'm just a moment away
from this maybe even prep it before
playing f5
mmm I'm just forgetting that the night
could be challenged right away okay um I
don't want that exchange what do I want
I really don't know
yeah I have to be careful if I'm doing
this this is sensitive huh maybe that
isn't the way
is this the way maybe it is the way now
takes one what am I talking about real
I just don't know okay let's try b5
maybe here then I have the less to worry
about what this night yeah let me let me
promote a night to rank for if I if
possible right now the battle between
these two nights I'm winning third rank
versus second rank these two are kind of
offset I think my rook is a tiny bit
better and my King is a tiny bit better
like a bit more secure
okay um can I
let's go for this I this this plan and
here
you
let's try this I wanted to get the
this this rook will quickly make use of
this square
oh oh oh oh I should have I should have
gone for something else
this manoeuvre I I missed that that
let's go here yeah I miss play these
last couple moves
Oh though they're giving me no let me
try for this
I don't I die shouldn't be trying to
give up that pawn or give up this square
let's put my knight here and now this
move some I'm out now this night is
really in rough shape I have pawns that
control the night and next up I'm gonna
look for this move maybe even prove my
king first or I should probably just get
on with this a for rookie one a for
what's this Knight gonna do or something
like this now he's gone on that
direction let's go here hard to take and
then take here and prepare to take am i
waiting upon are forcing this move am i
winning a poem I'm winning a poem I'm
winning h4 it's an open file but there's
no entry points let's just take I could
take here if pawn takes in-betweener
with check take with the pawn control
the night I'm up two pawns now and
looking to still play a a four
undermines c4 though I want this rook to
not allow the white rook to get
activated let's insert it now let's go
here let's go after this base point
night exchange I'm cool with any tricks
maybe we could go here ready to take and
then go here or this this pond will be
fast
ahead on the clock just by a hair let's
wipe upon change and sorry to check and
then play here demote the king no time
Oh what am i doing that was unfortunate
I was thinking there was a square
separating okay they're down on time and
I guess the final position is still
winning but don't do that next time
please yeah just just trow your hook
away
you